There's one other feature of cameras that I'm going to mention in passing here.
Depth of field. This is the idea of simulating a real camera, where you can
focus the lens to be at a particular distance. In depth of field algorithms,
you control the focal distance and also how blurry objects will appear when not
in focus. This type of algorithm is often done as a post-process. In other
words, data is collected by rendering the scene, then image processing of some
sort is used on this data to produce the final depth of field image. The
difficult part is getting objects in the foreground to be blurry and also
properly blend with the objects in focus behind them. 3JS has a demo showing a
depth of field effect. It may show up a bit dark here. So see the additional
course materials for the link and give it a try. It avoids the problem of
blurry foreground objects by putting the focus nearby. So that only distant
objects are fuzzy. There are other less expensive techniques you can do to get
a depth of field effect. Here's a simple tilt shift post process that gives
foreground and background blur. No scene information is used. A variable blur
is just added to the top and bottom of the final image.